ladies and gentlemen from all around the
world. Today is Sunday July the 27th
2025 and we gathered here in south of
Gaza Strip most share our concerns about
the ongoing crisis in Gaza Strip. During
the humanitarian crisis that Gaza and
his people are undergoing
food in general and flour bread
especially is becoming luxurious and
rare. it's not available for the
citizens. So our mission here to support
the citizens and to help them their
lives to be better by giving them these
trips. On behalf of those citizens and
those families, we thank God forever for
his wonderful support. It will be a
reason and making the people happy.
Thank you for being a reason in this
effort. [music]
Ever.
[music]
>> So, I'm Muslim.
>> Yes.
>> And my partner, she's Christian,
Orthodox.
>> Okay. And basically I wanted some like
um advice and guidance on like how I can
go about this. So I've done a bit of
research.
>> Yeah. And I know she here
>> she is. Yeah.
>> Can we talk to Hello. How are you?
>> How you doing?
>> Is he looking after you?
>> Cuz if he's not, you can talk to me and
I'll put him in his place. [laughter]
>> Okay. Are you guys married?
>> Not yet.
>> You can marry a Christian.
>> Yes. I've done the research. I basically
I've got issues with my family and
they're like she's not Muslim. It's not
right. Stuff like
>> No. Islamically she's a Christian. You
can marry her.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean don't disrespect your family. I'm
not I'm not asking you to do that. But
what I would say is in a nutshell is
that um
>> you can marry.
>> So you you can marry do marry
>> cuz that make things more halal and you
can't. So see this the beauty of Islam.
The reason why a Muslim woman cannot
marry a Christian or a Jew but you can
is because number one you cannot force
your religion on her.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yes. And uh number two, Muslim
woman has Islamic rights and the
Christian or the Jewish husband might
force into and not give her the Islamic
rights cuz it's not obligate upon him to
do that. It's a for you to do that
towards her.
>> Yeah.
>> So I would say what's stopping you guys
from getting married? Secondly, what are
the issues are you facing down parents?
>> Well, with my mom, she's like basically
it's the culture and it's the religion
as well like the nar. She's like cuz
she's Christian, you can't do a nar. You
can you can do
>> and that's basically I wanted to talk to
you about like how can I go around that
cuz my family are adamant and because
she's not Muslim you'll never be able to
nag you can't live a halal life. No, you
can.
>> And and that's what I've been I've
spoken to the imam as well in my local
masid and they it's the same thing
basically. They're like the imam said
that
>> they're trying to say basically find
yourself a Muslim wife because it's
easier. But I'm just like
>> no sorry with all due respect Allah if
Allah says yes I don't care what imam
says.
>> Exactly.
>> Without due respect if Allah says yes I
don't care if all the imams in the world
come and say we follow Allah bro. Yeah.
So if the im I understand they can come
and talk about you know being respectful
to your parents and you should be
respectful to your parents. try to
explain to them but obviously I want to
be careful. I don't want you to be
disrespectful to your parents. That's
very important. Number two, you need to
understand that you as a man do not need
a guardian
>> to marry. So you can marry her tomorrow,
bro.
>> Okay.
>> Do you get it? Now obviously you want
your parents on board because it's very
important.
>> Yeah.
>> And I understand maybe in a dilemma
where you do love her
>> and you're in between you and your
family.
>> It might require patience. It might
require time.
>> So I would say personally the first
thing is first you want to make things
halal. Of course,
>> because your parents on the day of
judgment, bro, they're going to throw
you in hellfire instead of yourself.
That's the reality of the day of
judgment. It's my mom and dad as well.
Everyone's going to be like it's
everyone's on their own.
>> So, you need to make things right with
your Lord.
>> So, before your parents, God almighty.
So, make things halal. Okay.
>> Yes. You can do the nikah. Yeah.
Actually, we we we sometimes conduct
nikas here. [laughter]
>> Some we don't run a man or woman. She
says that.
>> Yeah. So, it's not that long. Uh-huh.
>> Um, obviously I don't know where's
where's she hazmhyus.
>> He's busy. Okay. I was going to ask him
some questions regarding the ruling of
>> um cuz I don't know like you have to ask
for a dowy.
>> Yeah.
>> But I don't know if that's for a Muslim.
I'm not sure. That's what I was going to
ask him.
>> Mhm.
>> Sorry.
>> Oh, sorry. Chef,
he's a Muslim.
>> She's a Christian.
>> They want to marry. The parents don't
want it. And some imams even said that
it's not allowed. I said Allah said it
is allowed.
>> Yeah. Who says it's not? some imam he
said he's not he's not allowed to marry
a Christian
>> yeah they said it's it's difficult it's
difficult moving forward with like kids
and stuff like that
>> no no this is allowed to say it's
difficult look look
>> I don't know any imam that would say
you're not allowed because in the Quran
it says clearly that you are allowed to
marry yeah so that's that's the thing
some of them may put these kind of
obstacles in front of you by saying look
kids and this and the other because
Islamically
>> the kids follow the father.
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah.
>> Come here.
>> Sorry.
>> Islamically the kids follow follow the
father.
>> But us to marry her, it's the best thing
to do so that you don't fall in haram.
That's what I said. So you know you
don't want to fall in haram.
>> What's the rights of her? Does she can
she have dowi?
>> Okay. What's the right
>> you see sister? We got him unlocked.
Don't worry. We're going to we're going
to be telling you all the rights now.
Yeah, I know. I know the weather's cold.
He's already sweating.
>> He has Let me Let me grab him by his
neck as well so he knows the pressure.
>> I have to give you a diary.
>> You don't have to work. He has to go out
and and support the family.
>> This sounds fantastic.
>> Rent I'm getting excited on your paying
rent. Rent paying paying for food.
Paying for bills. Everything comes out
of it.
>> You're finished. You are rich.
[laughter] Even if you're rich, your so
your wealth is your wealth.
>> I thought I thought of Islam oppressed
woman. What's going on?
>> Yes. So, so this is this is Islamically
how he uh he can now.
>> So, so all the rights of a Muslim right
had had your father being a Muslim, he
has to ask his your hand from him,
>> you know.
>> Yeah. And uh but he can still do it. He
can still ask for for your hand from
your father and the only the only thing
that your father cannot join you to him
in marriage because you need to have
what we call ui
and the needs to be Muslim
>> she's a Christian. Why does the wi have
to be Muslim? I'm just curious.
>> Because he's given her into
in the name of Allah and the sunnah. I
thought she was a beaver. Yeah, but
she's not. And by the way, can
>> No, no, no, no. Even even No. For a
Christian,
>> she still needs a wally.
>> She still needs a wally.
>> And if I'm not mistaken, she I'm just
I'm learning as well. Yeah. She doesn't
need to wear a hijab as a Christian,
right?
>> No, she doesn't.
>> Interesting.
>> We wear it in church.
>> Yeah. In church, you have to
>> when we're inside the church.
>> So, sister, let me ask you a question.
>> Paul said that.
>> Okay. Why Why don't you become a Muslim?
>> It's just not what I believe in. I
respect his belief. Okay. Okay. Good.
So, I'm going to have to be I have to do
the pros and the cons.
>> Yeah.
>> So, there's a pro pros that obviously
you you know her.
>> Yeah.
>> She's like a lovely sister. I know
you're a lovely man.
>> You do also realize which religion would
your children be because that's an issue
like cuz I have to mention the pros and
the cons. Sometimes what happens is when
you and we don't wish that on anybody.
Sometimes I know people have married a
Christian.
>> Mhm.
>> They go their separate ways
>> and the the the the mother will bring
them up as children as Christians.
>> Okay.
>> That's the cons.
>> Yeah. So what I would say is this
sister, what evidence do you require to
become a Muslim? Is there something
that's stopping you? Is there something
where you're like, you know what, it
doesn't make sense? What's stopping you
from saying okay like okay, let me put
it like this. Is Islam on the table for
you or Islam is out the table
completely?
>> No, I like lying about it.
>> Okay, good. So do you know what we
believe
>> Islamically like?
>> Okay, good. Let me tell you what we
believe because it might be that you
might say, you know, actually I believe
that also for example, do you believe in
God? Good. Do you believe God is one?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Do you believe God is a man or a
woman?
>> Can God be a man or a woman?
>> No. No.
>> Good. Okay. Do you believe God can be a
statue like an idol?
>> No.
>> Good. Perfect. Do you believe there's
nothing like God?
>> Yeah.
>> Good. Okay. Now, what you believe there
takes you out of the fold of
Christianity. You go to any church,
Catholic, protest and say to them, I
believe God cannot be a man or a woman.
There's nothing like God. They'll say,
"Sorry, we believe Jesus is God." So,
you can't be a Christian. What you just
said now automatically takes you out the
fold of Christianity. Because Christians
believe in what? They believe in the
Trinity. Do you believe Jesus is God?
>> We believe he's part of God.
>> Not we. I'm asking you, what's your
name, sister?
>> Alex.
>> Sister Alex.
>> You what you just said now was rational
and logic. Do you believe God Jesus was
a man like me? Can God be a man like me?
Good. Where that's coming from is what
we call in Islam the fra.
>> The natural
>> fra means the way God has programmed you
to know who he is. So it's a natural
disposition. That's why we believe
everyone's born a Muslim. Yeah. I came
to Islam 13 years ago. But we was all
born with the inclination to know that
God is one. There is nothing like him.
So you believing that takes you out the
fold of Christianity. If you believe God
is one unique, not a man or a woman,
doesn't have a father and a mother or a
child or a daughter, there is nothing
like him. You can't be a Christian. You
are more closer to Islam than you are to
Christianity. You go to any church and
say, "I believe Jesus was a prophet of
God and I believe there's nothing like
God." They'll say, "Sorry." They'll say,
"Are you a Muslim?" You say, "No, I'm a
Christian." So, you can't be a
Christian. So, what you actually believe
is closer to Islam. So my second
question, what is your take on Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him?
>> I don't know too much.
>> Good. You don't know too much. Okay.
What about the Quran? What do you think
about the Quran?
>> I don't know.
>> Perfect. Okay. Good. So, all right.
Okay. So, we're at a good step. First
thing, first of all, what I would say,
sister Alex, is the following. You are
closer to Istan than you are to
Christianity. And I'm not just saying
this. Go to a church and test it out.
So, don't think I'm trying here to
convince you. Go to any church and say,
"I believe there's nothing like God.
He's not a man or a woman." They'll say,
"Look, we believe Jesus is God and he
was a man." So you already have the
inclination and the belief of a Muslim.
So if anything, you are closer to Islam.
Now I can prove to you the prophet
Muhammad being a prophet and I can prove
to you the Quran being the word of God
if you have the time.
>> You're a bit struck on time.
>> Okay.
>> So what I would say is the following.
You can still marry her. So she if he if
he if he if he marries her and she ends
up being a Muslim, do they need to do
again?
>> No.
>> Okay. No. So it's a win-win. So, for
example, look, he's he's crying. He's so
emotional. Look, he's like, "I love I
want to marry Alice." He's crying. I'm
joking. I get in the cold some eyes get
tearary. So, I think it's love. Say it's
love. It's all right. Don't cry. It's I
can see the love in your eyes.
>> Okay. So, what I would say is this,
sister, look into it. Have you read the
Quran before?
>> No.
>> Okay. Good. Do you know we believe in
Jesus?
>> Do you know we believe in Mary?
>> Good. You know we believe he's the
Messiah and we believe he's going to
come back. We believe in like you being
a Muslim it's as if you become a real
Christian because we believe the real
Jesus. We believe in Mary. We believe in
his miracles. So what I would say is
sister you do seem sincere. You seem
like you have a good heart. You seem
like you come from a good place. Your
beliefs are close to Islam. So I would
say look into it. The Quran has miracles
within itself that if you had time I
would have got into it. Look at the
prophet Muhammad's life. Look into that
inshallah. And all I could say is pray
to God. One thing I would ask you guys
to do specifically yourself,
>> pray to God and say, "God, if this is
the truth, guide me."
>> That's what I would say in Do you have
any questions for me?
>> Um, the only question I wanted to ask
with the naga, how can I go about it?
>> You got You can do it in 2 minutes. No
joking.
>> No. What what what you need to do is you
just need an imam.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh, do you live in London?
>> No, I live in Red Hill near Gatwick
Airport.
>> Near Gatwick Airport.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I think I think the nearest place
to you is Crawley, isn't it?
>> Crawley is not too far.
>> It's not too far. Yeah. So you go to
Crawley, go to a maj
to do for me. I don't want to be in the
I want I want and they will do it.
>> Okay.
>> They will do it. So basically you and
her
>> Yeah.
>> And two witnesses.
>> Okay.
>> Muslim witnesses too. And it's easy. the
if I was the imam I will ask her that I
will be her wally
>> so kind of like I will give her to you
in marriage
>> okay
>> and it's easy they say do you take this
this woman Alex daughter of James for
example Alex daughter of James for for a
wife you say you say yes I do and I say
I agree and that's it and the is done
>> it's very simple then
>> it's very simple it it it will take 5
minutes.
>> Okay.
>> It will 5 minutes. But that is that is
the
for you, the Islamic way, the proper
way. And she is your wife in halal.
>> Yeah. And that's Yeah. That's literally
just what I wanted to know. Those
>> in halal, brother.
>> Yeah. Cuz a lot of people have been
>> Don't go to the haram, brother.
telling me cuz she's not Muslim, you
can't do a nagar. It doesn't work.
>> No, brother. She is from the people of
the book.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's what I've been
telling. I tell you, I believe it's it's
chapter 6. No. Uh, chapter 5 verse 6.
>> Chapter 5 verse 6.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And you can ask for diary. Sorry.
Do you know what you're going to be
asking?
>> Sorry.
>> You can ask anything by the way.
>> Yes. I'll take it easy on him. But yeah,
you can you know genuinely it's your
right. You can ask whether you like. Uh
you can you can give installment plans
when No.
No. If she asks like, let's say she
asked for £5,000 and she tells you, "I
will pay £500 in 10 installments."
>> You can.
>> Yeah. No, I'm serious. I'm serious.
That's right. Yes. You can have mercy on
him. Yes. Or a ring and holiday and you
know, whatever you want. In Okay,
perfect. In I hope God almighty guide
you guys and call us to your wedding.
>> Make sure biryani. Thank you [laughter]
very much.
>> Nice talking to you guys. May Allah
bless you guys. Nice meeting you guys.
May Allah guide you. Oh yeah, they're
going to love this.